good morning believe nation today's
messages stay confident over to you
Stephen Curry what teams obviously try
to stop you that's the way to stop the
Warriors cut the head off the snake the
by that you at times last year in the
playoffs what have you learned from that
experience that uh those times a
temporary just keep my confidence keep
my aggressiveness I've prepared well to
this summer to continue to get better
and learn from those mistakes I'll call
they're gonna happen there's no avoiding
that but just making sure that it
doesn't kill your confidence and it
doesn't change the way you're playing
you got to be obviously you can get
smarter and kind of figure it out and
then maybe find other ways to impact the
game with us on the defensive end
getting stops getting steal pushing the
tempo
I always need to be making shots to
hopefully impact the game so so the
question today today is I'm curious as
to how do you stay confident for me it's
about creating that environment for
greatness it's about strano myself with
resources and famous entrepreneurs and
watching these clips and seeing great
people doing great things and being
courageous makes me feel like I want to
do something outside my box search my
comfort zone and that's what it is I
think for me at least if you want to
create something great you need first an
environment for greatness of work on
that first and I get that daily which
makes me confident daily in my abilities
to want to go and do something big
but I'm curious how do you stay
confident what do you do daily weekly
monthly to help that confidence rise
leave it in comments below I'm gonna
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso